[Music]
nodes up chasm kabhi HD here still in
Las Vegas and I've seen a lot of
self-driving tech so far here at CES
like if you walk through any of the
halls with cars in them there's tons of
like open room concepts and things like
that but they feel kind of useless you
know like as long as they're still on a
concept phase they don't really feel
really yet the idea is we're building
the interiors of these cars now for this
autonomous future where you don't have
to be sitting at the wheel so you can
turn around face your friends you kind
of feel like you're in a moving room
lots of glass it's very different and
I've seen a lot of that all over the
show floor really far out stuff crazy
shapes huge chunks of glass and stuff
built for autonomy actually BMW I think
had a sort of a happy medium they showed
me what they called the I next which is
sort of a really futuristic vision of a
next-gen car but not too far in the
future so it has these wide open spaces
and touch sensitive fabrics and surfaces
for gestures but it still sort of seems
like a normal car but still without the
actual self-driving tech in action as
just kind of half the story so then I
got an email from a company called
Yandex you may know them as a Russian
tech company and they said hey come
check out our autonomous car at CES I'm
kind of thinking okay well I've seen a
lot of autonomous concepts and things
like that how could this be much
different but then they said listen we
have a fully autonomous driverless car
hitting the streets of Las Vegas with
all the other regular cars right now you
can go for a ride you in so I super in
let's do it
[Music]
so the car itself is a retrofitted Prius
on top is radar lidar and camera array
for the car to map out its surroundings
I think I saw one who's used the
autopilot from a Tesla it helps me to
not be as nervous in the backseat but
it's still crazy not having anyone in
the driver's seat at all as the car
navigates the streets there's a safety
engineer in the passenger seat which had
a kill switch next to him for if
anything happened to go wrong or it
needed to be interrupted but we did
about a 15 minute loop around real
streets real drivers real people and
everything went smoothly and it was kind
of still trippy the whole time this this
really feels like the future I gotta say
it might not be this crazy soft driving
interior that everyone else is talking
about but this tech part is cool to me
the details are that this is a small
area in Las Vegas that was already
mapped by this company so it was a
predetermined route and the car knew
where it was gonna go but everything
else Road conditions
the other cars the pedestrians the
traffic lights the turns
speed changes all of that was decisions
made by the car but all that makes sense
for a taxi I mean you map the town or
city you want to be in you have
predetermined routes for pick-up and
drop-off and then the taxis are
driverless and they just go from there
and the even cooler nerdier part is
these iPad pros you're seeing that's a
visualization of what the sensors on top
of the car are seeing in real time so
the radar lidar and cameras are all
combining to identify what is other cars
on the road
what's pedestrians what is a stationary
object and seeing things up to 250
meters away in every direction
so things six seven cars away we're on
the iPad that I couldn't even see in
real life out the windows so there are
some red paths and when we start driving
you're gonna see some green paths and
basically what I'm seeing here is it's
evaluating what's currently happening on
the road and what's about to happen
red paths
green paths good and it takes the green
path and has a predetermined destination
we're on a left turning lane so you can
see way up ahead where it wants to go
and it's just gonna fall out where I
can't
based on the cars around us you can't
really merge right now so those paths
are red it has a green path and it has a
bunch of other possible paths to take if
it wants to switch it up but right now
it's all green and the best part is the
reaction from other people on the road
was pretty great there's people pulling
out their phones to record the
driverless car people kind of stare a
little bit at stoplights when they
realize what's going on and apparently
Las Vegas cops think it's pretty funny
too but overall the 15 minutes we've
spent in this car were a lot of fun I
learned a lot just looking at these
iPads and what they were seeing as the
car drove around and this gave me a sort
of an optimism for the future of
self-driving tech so that's pretty much
it figured I would share my experience
would you let yourself get driven in a
driverless taxi like this maybe share
this video with other people you think
would be interested and I'll leave some
links below with some more information
so you can look it up if you want to see
that too either way thanks for watching
see you guys next one peace